my biggest takeaway from skydiving if I  ever wanted to know what it was like to  put a leaf blower in my mouth  uh that is what skydiving is nobody  talks about that your mouth is blown  open and the airbrushes in your mouth is  already dry from nerves and all you want  to do is take a breath and have a sip of  water yeah I felt like I was playing  that game what's that thing that they  put in your mouth say it something like  you know yes like that yeah that's what  it is I forgot it's called but yes you  know what I'm talking about yes yes the  dental the dental thing that you put in  your mouth and then you have to say  words and people have to guess it back  and you literally feel like your whole  mouth is being that pulled back what I'm  talking about nobody talks about leaf  blower is a better better yeah Leaf  blows are good that's like a leaf blower  with your mouth after you've had those  gentle pull things out I was like I  can't breathe